I gotta say that the election results to
me the second most depressing story of
the week this was the first they said
human influence on the climate system is
clear they've said that for years they
said we are looking at an unprecedented
amount of carbon at least in the last
800,000 years and then they talked about
sea levels rise in the oceans are
becoming too acidic for anything to live
in them
you know crop yields will be down
drought so of course what do the
geniuses in America do they elect a
bunch of climate deniers and for those
people who say it doesn't matter who you
elect I want to show you a few quotes
here these are people who either lost or
were in office or didn't win out is this
guy from Iowa ran against Joni Ernst he
said climate disruption is real and
absolutely needs to be addressed Joni
Ernst says I have not seen proven proof
because she's an idiotic idiot that it
is entirely man-made I don't know the
science behind climate change
yes but there are people who do
I've heard arguments on both sides okay
Colorado mark Udall out he said
Colorado's persistent droughts excessive
mega fires and destructive floods show
why Congress needs to act ASAP the idiot
who took his place I don't think you
could say yes or no okay moving on
Alaska Mark Begich out urgentiy called
climate change this said the
jury is still out on climate change no
it's not Harry Reid of course out as
Majority Leader Harry said we should be
facing the reality of climate change
climate changes here Mitch McConnell of
course the king of coal denying global
warming is why he gets paid he says for
everyone who thinks it's warming I can
find someone who thinks it isn't yes the
lobbyists you have drinks with you Jim
and here's a Barbara Boxer was
heading the committee about the
environment right
she said manmade climate changes of
planetary emergency and one of the most
important challenges facing humankind
and of course now the guy taking over
James Inhofe the worst god still up
there he says the arrogance of people to
think that we human beings would be able
to change what he is doing in the
climate Wow see I love that
he's mad we shouldn't be mad he's mad
that we're even bringing this up because
God still up there well you have to be
ashamed these people are on your team
please tell me you're ashamed these
people are on
the guy from Colorado that you put up
there he also ran ads where he's
standing in front of wind farms talking
about how he wants to see an expansion
in green energy
it's what's really fascinating is you
can actually find a lot of Republicans
who want to see us come up with new ways
so that we're not giving me this look
like I'm a crazy person well I mean they
look at the poll shows half over half of
Republicans in polls say they believe
climate change is happening in half not
of the United States Congress
look I sit I sit on the Environmental
Committee dragged by California's
Barbara Boxer Bible has done a great job
in this issue well look two issues
number one the scientific community is
you have just indicated the debate is
over except within the Republican Party
right climate change is real it is
already causing devastating problems but
here's the second issue billeting gets
back to a very important issue it's not
that these Republicans are dumb they get
huge sums of money from the Koch
brothers and from the fossil fuel
industry and they are not going to stand
up to the people who contribute to their
campaigns it's not more complicated it's
gonna be wild though I mean senator
Inhofe from Oklahoma I've covered him
for five years he is not going to sit
back as committee chairman at the
Environment and Public Works I think
he's gonna be an activist chairman you
probably have an opinion on this as well
but this is a guy who wants to go after
climate change and yet and Bernie I
think you're under estimating their
stupidity I really I mean I think I
think Inhofe really believes God is
still up there and and when these people
say you know I I don't know about
climate change I'm not a scientist I
always want to say Jimmy you're not a
gynecologist you didn't didn't stop you
from talking about vaginas all those
years
no but that's the point no I don't agree
with you I don't think you know we have
in you think enough knows better
no Inhofe no I know Jim Inhofe and Jim
is a very nice guy yeah he believes what
he believes yes but you got other people
there who are in fact physicians who are
well educated people so ensue knows what
you're saying is the party is a
coalition of the greedy cynical and the
truly stupid what what but if you're
gonna run for them